[Music]
welcome back on July 20th Congress will
return to Washington with just one
objective hammering out the next
stimulus bill the bipartisan talks
happening just as the extra $600 in
weekly unemployment benefits is set to
expire at the end of the month joining
me right now is Republican Conference
Chairman senator john barrasso and
senator it's always a pleasure to see
you thank you so much for joining us
tell me what the dreamers are in terms
of the cares after or than the next part
of the cares Act another stimulus plan
yeah there's a consensus we need to do
another bill that'll be in the next
couple of weeks and let me just tell you
what I believe needs to be in it and I
think your viewers will agree number one
it has to focus on getting people back
to work and children back in school
number two it has to focus on saving
lives and to me that means more testing
better treatment and and then of course
a vaccine and finally we need to provide
the liability insurance for our health
care workers for our mom and pops small
businesses and for our schools so they
can all open in a good way now the
Democrats have a proposal already they
passed it a month or so ago and it's
Nancy Pelosi living in handout heaven
it's direct checks to illegal immigrants
it's bailouts to big city and state
pension plans that are run by Democrats
we're not going to do that the focus of
this bill has to be getting people back
to work and paychecks back into their
pockets so so you're back on July 20th
but then there's another recess
beginning on August 8th right do you
think in that three-week period you're
gonna get another stimulus plan passed
and signed before you leave again August
8th well there are a couple of deadlines
as you mentioned one is the enhanced
uninsurance unemployment insurance
benefits that run out on on July 31st
the other is the paycheck protection
program which has been so successful
that runs out on August 8th that's
helped keep about 50 million people on
their you know on a payroll and in
Wyoming we had 13,000 of those loans so
yeah there's a there
an urgency to get this done a lot of
different things in the components of it
the question is should it include
additional relief checks for people who
have still not been able to get back to
work certainly in hard-hit industries
whether it's a service industry the
hospitality industry you know we did
that once before but that was it people
up to $95,000 we're looking at a lower
number there and then the unemployment
insurance is you raised these are
enhanced benefits where they've been
paying people $600 a week above their
own state unemployment benefits right
and some of them are making more to stay
home rather than to go to work stay with
us senator I want to ask you about masks
and whether it should be a policy in
that next act as well we are talking
with Senator bra so we'll be right back
welcome back and we're back with Senator
John Barrasso and Senate I want to ask
you about masks and whether or not that
should be part of your cares Act there
are some states that have made wearing a
mask a policy should it be a national
policy well let me just say Maria as a
doctor I want to congratulate president
Trump for wearing his mask yesterday in
public for the world to see I think that
sends a very strong message to everyone
we know that masks lower the risk of
infection we know it lowers the risk of
death and in this recent uptick I just
think it's even more important than ever
and you know when it comes to opening
schools these are going to be local
decisions state decisions but I just
think in terms of good planning and good
health as people try to resume their
normal lives
masks personal hygiene washing their
hands
socially distancing that's all part of
this as we continue to fight this
disease all right and real quick on the
next cares act when you get back on the
20th it doesn't sound like you're gonna
leave on August 8th without anything
getting done should I assume we will
have another another stimulus package in
that three-week period there is general
agreement we need to work to that end
and we need to deal with the issues
affecting our nation there are still
people who can't go back to work through
no fault of their own because of the
disease because of
medical conditions we need to make sure
that they are cared for but we cannot
continue to pay people more to sit at
home then the go to work and we have so
many help wanted signs around Wyoming
and the country we need to do all we can
to get people back to work and help them
earn that paycheck
senator real quick before we go the
Senate unanimously passed that
bipartisan bill to sanction Chinese
officials who threatened Hong Kong's
Authority but the president hasn't it
signed it yet right what message does
this send to the Communist Party and
will we see this get signed into law do
you think well the Communist Chinese are
not our friends there is no question
about it my message to the Chinese is
never again never again will we as
Americans be dependent upon you the
Communist Chinese for medicines for
materials for minerals what you're
seeing here with what they're doing
mariya with this group with Hong Kong
with their the Chinese incursion into
the South China Sea it's all part of
their big plan to be the military the
economic and the technological
superpower world cannot allow senator
thank you